- Je sais pas si vous pouvez
voir ce qu'on a reçu. Je vous
montre ça tout de suite, vous
voyez?  Le premier... d'en bas,
c'est le grésil, et au-dessus,
il y a une couche de glace :
le verglas.
- Qui tombe beaucoup, c'est
de l'eau... beaucoup d'eau- Là,e
verglaçante, vous le voyez.
Donc, j'ai vérifié les nouvelles
données. Au total, 20 à 30 mm
de précipitations verglaçantes.
- Bonsoir, auriez-vous
des bonnes nouvelles?
- Malheureusement, non.
En fait, le pire est à venir.
J'ai atteint mon quota, je n'en
peux plus.
(rire)- Quels souvenirs pour un
météorologue pascal la crise du
verglas. On vous a eu avec
Bernard. Vous étiez
littéralement, vous couchiez à
Radio-Canada en 98.
- Je pense que j'ai travaillé 90
heures. Le premier soir j'ai
rentrer à la maison mais avait
commencé le matin à six heures.
Je suis rentré à la maison en
après-midi je suis retourné dans
le cas de soir je suis rentré en
fin de soirée coucher à la
maison, à partir de mardi je
dormais Radio-Canada. Où je
pouvais. Par ce que c'était
vraiment improvisé. Je laisserai
une banquette ou un matelas. On
m'avait offert de dormir à
l'infirmerie à l'époque.
J'essayais de retrouver un peu
de sommeil parce que j'étais
complètement, vovie un
moment donné je l'ai dit: je
n'en peux plus. Relevant le
jeudi j'étais complètement vidé.
C'était très physique.
- Évidemment poanada
avoir météorologue dans une
crise de cette ampleur là, vous
étiez unxtraordinaire.
Pour expliquer aux gens, parce
que c'est un phénomène qu'on n'a
pas revu à ce point là,
exceptionnel.
- Non jamais on n'a jamais revu
ça. Ça a duré quand même cinq
jours. Ça commence dans la nuit
du dimanche à lundi, on a une
première dose le lundi mardi, Ça
duré toute la semaine. Par
endroits ça dépassé les 100 mm
d'épaisseur. Montréal salarié de
40 à 80. Il y a 28 morts. 5
millions de personnes touchées.
Panne de courant jusqu'à quatre
semaines. À Montréal la plupart
des gens ont été privés de
courant pendant la semaine.
C'est au moins 3,4 milliards de
dollars de dégâts.
- Je me souviens des pylônes. Il
tombait comme si c'était en
plastique. Pourquoiveiveiveiveie
plus? Qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
pour expliquer c'était
exceptionnel?
- Quand on entend pas de
verglas, un épisode de verglas
ça dure une journée maximum.
C'était de tout au plus mais la
sonnerie de la semaine parce que
il y a eu quatre perturbations.
En fait la tempête verglas C4
perturbations qui ont avec le
continent. Une première qui est
passée dans la nuit de dimanche
à lundi une suivant qui a
commencé le lundi, ça c'est
c'est le mardi ça reprit le
mercredi puis on a une nouvellee
jeudi jusqu'au vendredi. Quatre
perturbations qui ont déposé
jusqu'à 100,110 mm plus verglas
sang. La Montérégie a été le
plus touché. Dans ces régions,
c'était le placard total à
partir de mercredi. Le centre-
ville de Montréal, Black out à
partir de jeudi et vendredi.
C'était une catastrophe totale.
Les usines d'opérations des eaux
de Montréal sont tombées en
panne. On a eu peur de manquer
d'eau.
dans lesdans lesdans lesdans les
épiceries. Pour acheter de
l'eau. C'était extrême.
- Il n'a rien qui top ça pour un
météorologue en termesline et dé
que, vous êtes entré dans les
changements climatiques après.
- Oui, évidemment ne parlait pas
vraiment de changement
climatique à cette époque on
restait assez prudent mais on voyait
le caractère exceptionnel de l'événement.
Quel est la récurrence de ça?
C'est extrêmement ça dire.
centaines d'années. Mais ce que
ça pourrait se reproduire, c'est
très très difficile à dire.
C'est tellement ex
durée cinq jours, mais l'idée
c'est que il faut croire que
cette an
Nino hiss
étranger à ce qui s'est passé.
Ce n'est pas la seule raison
mais c'est un facteur qui a joué
là-dedans. Quatre perturbations
sont suivies et qui ont apporté
de la plus verglas semble perdu
presque toute la semaine. Je nex
arriver. On les voyait arriver,
je me rappelle que j'ai dit à
Bernard voilà il y en a
plusieurs s'en vienne. Envoyer
les événements armés. Pour moive
physique.
- Je comprends, dit-il en tout
temps.
- Je commence à six heures du
matin je finissais à minuit voir
une heure du matin. Vous pou
voir la fatigue dans le visage.
Ça c'était le premier soir. On
entendait les branches tombées,
les transformateurs qui
éclataient. Et ça c'était le dernier soir,
je lui avais dit "Écoutez, là c'est de
la neige qui tombe maintenant.
C'est terminé".  C'était vraiment la lumière
au bout du tunnel.